illa Elohim Allah God which one doesn't
which one doesn't belong yeah see God is
nothing he'll break it break it down
again you said illa illa illa him in the
Hebrew Bible ela Elohim Elohim Allah
Allah
God which one doesn't belong God they
brought up this name in the 15th century
yeah when they translated the Bible into
the German languages and other languages
they brought the name God in my first
and second Jihad book I proof that the
etymology of God it means an idol and
either but now you're saying our
tradition is judeo-christian there they
believed in the Old Testament with the
Old Testament has never said the word
God Jesus has never said the word God he
said Allah Allah Elohim I I found
encyclopaedia britannica
when you when they trace it back to the
language that he spoke Aramaic many have
found that he said Aloha have you heard
this Aloha ya la ilaha doesn't know this
is even closer than Allah no no that uh
at the end yeah it's true for respect
Allah ha-ah so that's for respect in the
Arabic language but you know masha'Allah
you have a good brain and I ask Allah so
Harry taught that we have so many like
your brother I shall live doing so much
for his channel Allah you know him Allah
God why would you come and say Allah
doesn't belong God does what's wrong
with you man so that's what you told her
the 15th century until now they use the
word God but the original Bible doesn't
have it
the Paul has never said God in any way
or form including when he was writing in
the European languages ok he never said
God what did you bring back from now
what was they say no he said Jehovah
yahuwah yahuwah is one way of saying
Allah by rearranging the word it's
according to the community you lived in
the language they are how they addressed
Allah
still you have the aleph and the lamb
and the hair in it
so jehovah the colonies yeah well he's
allah that's that's that's a loss oh
yeah yeah yeah so we don't have no
objection to that
absolutely not now how do you connect it
again illa illa illa illa illa illa hem
which is in the Hebrew Bible and the old
New Testament books before the 15th
century Allah
Elohim Allah God but the Jehovah part
how did you explain that again for
people because the letters to let that
confirm you know it is one way of saying
Allah - in Abu Bakr actually this is a
Hebrew world yeah Abu Bakr once had
something there is the companion of the
problem yeah yeah he's the successor of
the salah salem the muslims considering
the best man ever
after muhammad's allah allah and his
khalifa not Isis Felipa he's the
original good Khalifa once he heard the
statement he didn't like he said by
Allah this statement did not come from
an ill allah means died their deity see
it means dirty now the Hebrews used el
Allah you know him
Muslims use Allah el allahumma whatever
Hager so when you hear yahuwah it has
the same foundation that comes to my ear
that it confirms what the Hebrews and
the Arabs used to call Allah narrator
and this includes alehissalaam this is
very perfect cause you have a whole
people stuck without the true name of
God so people are saying god they don't
even many people don't even say jehovah
they don't they say it they equate Jesus
they put him in there and they say the
Father what I often tell people our
Christian friends out there
I often and what do you think about this
tell them look the Lord's Prayer it's
very powerful it says o our Father who
art in heaven if you just say how you
know AB rub dub is father rub is Lord
did they when they call on God they say
the Father we
don't call him father but we would say
this is Allah this is this is the crater
and if they stick to this prayer only
praying because Jesus is not in this
prayer and then it says Oh your will be
done not anyone elses this is Islam this
is a great place for people to start for
seeking guidance isn't it what do you
think I think you're hitting it man yeah
listen let me complete the thought about
Elisha being a prophet of islam he
caught the same monotheism monotheism
monotheistic ideology that Muhammad
called to Musa Moses called to Abraham
Noah everybody so all the prophets came
consistently with the same faith now
they didn't call it Islam during the
time of Asia maybe they did we don't
know there is so much of that history we
don't know exactly what exactly he said
or didn't say but the faith is the same
and I proved it in Hollywood who says
you had edition number one number two
approved it from the Bible yeah
so now they're there they mention the
Creator they say the word father Islam
doesn't object to describing allah as
being the father if the meaning is the
one who takes care of his people we are
a las creation he promised he's gonna
take care of us like a father takes care
of his family so in that context it's
fine okay why muslims now objected we
losing it describing allah because the
christians meant it literally that's the
problem now now saying that he had a
literal son and he was the literal
father but you're explaining it where
like a father who takes care
you